All right, welcome back everyone. Um, I
think this week is going to be a really,
really fun conversation between Dasher
and I about a topic that I thought was
going a little viral for a bit. Uh, many
of you might have seen the Manis paper
that came out about all their findings
about context engineering and other such
related things about what benefit um
what benefits that they saw with some of
the techniques that they did. For those
of you that didn't, no worries. we're
gonna go describe all of them and we'll
talk about the trade-offs. But I think
in general the most interesting thing
about that whole thing that I saw was
just how deep this stuff goes. Like it a
lot of us take for granted or it's like
we learned the first level. It's good.
But a lot of the stuff goes really deep
and it's all based out of the
foundational stuff behind how these LLMs
work. It's not always even obvious how
you would predict that if you don't
actually understand how an LM produces
tokens. I think that's kind of what we
should talk about today and how these
findings cannot Go ahead, Dexter.
>> Sorry. No, and like I I really love the
the way you frame that which is like um
there are things that are just
completely beyond your understanding and
they're not hard to understand, but if
you don't know to learn about them and
you don't know to go research them and
figure out how the stuff works under the
hood, uh because none of us is going to
go and get a machine learning PhD in the
next two weeks. But um if you can find
certain things and find understanding of
how things work under the hood um there
are certain slices you can take of that
knowledge that can make you a much
better AI engineer.
>> Yeah. And I think part of the
conversation today is not just going to
be about how what those learnings are
but how you could derive them for first
principles so that you can go on and
perhaps find new things on your own
because I think that's the most valuable
insight. It's not about being able to
copy what other people do. It's being
able to figure out what is a thing that
you can invent and help the rest of us
along the way because if all of us with
all our different backgrounds can go and
investigate these areas, I think we can
converge on what makes good AI pipelines
way faster as a general community
building this stuff out.
>> So,
>> with that,
>> do you want to do quick intros and then
I have a quick announcement and then
let's get into it.
>> Um, cool. So, I'm Dex. Uh, I, uh, well,
the announcement is basically if you're
new to the show, we post every episode
on GitHub. Um, and so you can come here
and see all of them. Uh, if you're
looking for the recaps of the context
engineering for AI agent stuff, you can
find that here. We've done a lot of
episodes on context engineering in the
past. Um, and so just another reminder,
encouragement, we put all of the links,
all the show notes will be here in the
Git repo, um, including links to sign up
for the next episode and all the
whiteboards that we publish. So, um,
without without, uh, further ado, I'm
Dex. I'm the founder of Human Layer. Um,
we've been doing the show since March.
Uh, and uh, this is this is AI that
works, where we teach you to be a better
AI engineer. I don't know. By, you're
gonna have to you're gonna have to pitch
the show for me.
>> Um, I'm Bob. I write some code. That's
about it. Let's talk about fun stuff.
Let's get to the meat.
>> Let's do it.
>> Um, one second. Context engineering.
ESD. Cool.
And now I'm going to go ahead and
screen.
So, I want to go straight into the manus
paper and just go talk about this uh
from the very beginning. I Dexter, I
don't have a second screen today, so
you're going to have to keep be on the
lookout for questions people ask and
just let me know
>> as we go.
>> So, I think
>> you want to make me a host.
>> Yes. I'm surprised I did not do that
already.
>> All right. So, the first thing is like
what is Manis? For those that haven't
seen, it's a pretty pretty cool project
that got a lot of popularity. Um, it's
based I've not signed in. It's bas uh
they still have the the like videos on
the website where you can like see the
like example use cases.
>> Yeah, I think it's probably worth
looking at because I think it tells you
roughly what it is. It basically kind of
just does stuff. It's an agent that is
very generalized and does stuff. Um, and
it's really impressive what it was able
to do.
Um, from it's going to make me sign and
I'll show you guys. And I think part of
what made this app so viral and
impressive is the fact that these folks
figured out some ways to
stop asking just let me show you
what to do. But you'll notice, okay, I
don't have enough credits. Okay, I
already used all my credits when I was
doing this earlier. But um part of what
made the app really impressive was just
how broad of a task it was able to do
and how like how high quality it was
able to handle for the generality of
what it did. And there's small things
like I don't know if you guys noticed
just like when I was even on the
homepage
there's small things here that get
really fast. I do this and it
immediately fills in these things. How
is it so freaking fast? We're all using
the same models. It's not like they have
anything special under the hood. And
these small things around how they
design the UX, how they design the
interfaces, how they make the models
slightly faster are what I think made
Madness go viral because it's one of the
first apps to go do that. I think when
they announced on their techniques, one
of the most talked about techniques was
around this idea of a KV cache, but I'll
talk about that in a little bit later.
Um, it talked about another concept
called masking not removing. And there's
this concept when we use MCPS which goes
around this idea of like how do you deal
with the fact that I don't want to give
my model every single tool all the time
and why you don't want to do that makes
sense cuz I don't want my model to be
dumb and like have choices between tools
it shouldn't have. If it's going to
choose between writing a document and I
know the user wants a notion document,
don't give it the Google Docs tools.
That is literally just going to confuse
it. That makes a lot of sense. But
there's trade-offs in this and what
happens. So we'll talk about that in a
second.
It talked about how you actually
engineer for super large context and
context compression. I didn't use that
word specifically, but I think that's
what they were hinting at, which help
you intelligently compress context when
you have
>> and it's using right.
>> Yeah,
>> this is using basically the same tools
that agents already know how to use a
file system basically. And so it becomes
a really nice way for the agent to
organize its own memories, right?
>> Kind of at least from what I understood.
It might be slightly different. Um, and
I think the other thing that I thought
was um, when he talked about this
concept of how it actually summarizes
steps, this was very similar if you were
here in last episode when Dexter was
talking about how it he does
summarization for his coding workflow
where he does like a research step, a
planning step, and then an execution
step. And the whole idea is you're able
to compress context in a more concise
way simply by some of the techniques
that they discuss here. Um, they talked
about keeping the wrong stuff in and
like how that hurts your system. And
then thing that I often say which is
fuchia prompting sucks. They talk about
why they also found fuchia prompting
sucks
uh more often than not but we'll go into
some of these now for everyone else. Um
just to give us an idea how many of you
have actually read through this or have
ideas around what this thing is so we
know what kind of conversation we're
going to be having today.
>> Is this the one that mentions I think I
saw it as you scrolled up the number of
tool uses that an agent should make.
That's something I remember. I can't
remember if that was talked about here
or not.
>> No, that's not this one. This one does
not talk about the number of tool uses.
>> Okay, so that was like five or something
that I remember.
>> Perfect. In that case, let's just start
with the first one. Designing around the
KV cache. I think that is the most
interesting one out of all of them
because it really inspires
um for everything else around this. And
there's no reason to actually do any
pre-ereading. That's kind of why we have
this conversation over here. Dexter and
I do this stuff for fun and we just get
share about it with you everyone.
>> So, one second. I'm gonna go screen
share, but I think the most important
thing I'm gonna want is a whiteboard.
So, let me pull that up, Dexter.
>> Oh, yeah. Let me let me ship you a
whiteboard.
I'm just gonna buy you a $7 a month for
a whiteboard account. Just Just
>> I don't know if you just like it because
the best part is when you do it, I can
ask you to take the screenshots and not
me. [laughter]
>> Fair enough.
Um, I sent it to you at Slack.
>> Perfect.
And I'm going to go back to screen
sharing. So let's talk about what it
means to design around the K KV cache.
So firstly, when we're act what does it
what what does a KV cache mean? What
what is actually happening? So let's
just start off with the basics of what
an LM is. An LM is a thing that takes in
a bunch of tokens, spits out a bunch of
token probabilities and then you somehow
will apply some algorithm typically like
a soft max or something.
um
to then pick out what is the token that
I should actually be selecting.
And these are just probabilities of
final output tokens. And once you select
your next token, then the LLM will take
this thing back. I don't know how to
draw this arrow, but I suspect will fix
it for me. It'll add this to it'll
append this selected token to the very
next um uh item on the array. and then
it'll just append it and it'll go back
in a loop over and over again. Most of
us probably know this how alams work.
The thing that I think a lot of people
don't realize
is this if you've done software probably
looks like a dynamic programming
problem. This looks like a thing where
you have almost the same array going in
over and over again but then you just
have one new element every single time.
It sounds like we should be able to
repeat some of the math and not have to
redo everything all the time.
If you actually go look into here, what
you'll find is the LM has some
architecture stuff in here that allows
it to not have to repeat all the math
all the time, assuming that you have
some of the stable, some stability
guaranteed. So you can premputee some of
this stuff as a part of the encoder
decoder layer that the LM has inside of
itself. The problem is that precomputed
section is purely dependent on
continuity. So you it's very hard for
you to premputee
um like random segments of it. What you
can do is much easier to premputee
chunks of it along the way. And I should
be using different colors.
So you can premp compute this part, you
can premputee this part, and then you
can premputee this part.
>> I I'm sorry. I'm not quite clear what
like the vertical access means in here.
>> What I mean by here is like the tokens
going in. These are all the tokens that
are in from like index zero. So I should
what I mean by here is like this is
index zero this is index one
and like these are just tokens
>> okay zero index zero index one might be
like
>> the word exactly
>> it would be like
>> think of it like a string that I drew
vertically because of how the model is
laid out and that's easier for me to
think about
>> uh and then you have like index like
>> I see okay so you're caching the first
three words in the sentence and then
once you come back with this next like
once you come back with the the fourth
word in the sentence here that is like
four
uh
and then you ask okay what's the next
token all of all of this part of it
basically is is cached all the math for
this part of it is cached and so you're
just kind of like taking that pre-filled
um whatever they're like matrix of the
meaning of what's being accumulated in
the transformer and so you're just kind
of it's all cost and timing, right? It's
like it's much faster to just say,
"Okay, cool. Now here's the next token.
Now give me the next inference bit."
Right.
>> Exactly. And just to be very clear, like
I know some of you are like, "Ah, but
technically doesn't the walking word
impact what all the other words mean. So
like how can you actually cache this?"
Very
>> great question.
>> Turns out
>> I would not have asked that question.
That's a great question.
>> Well, it turns out the transformer has
like two different parts, encoders and
decoders that are all laid out.
As it turns out, you don't actually run
all the computation all at once. You
actually break down the input string
into smaller subsequences of strings
that then can each be individually
computed and then you can go on stacking
that along the way. So if you go on to
like Enthropic's caching docs,
um we just go here for example,
you'll find that Enthropic has a minimum
cacheable prompt. They do that because a
problem less than 10 24 tokens probably
doesn't fit in whatever cache alignment
block that they have for actually doing
the computation behind some architecture
decisions that they have made. And it
wouldn't make sense for them to catch
that because it's basically throwaway
work because every token outside of 124
is going to cross compete cross um uh
need to do some like cross tension stuff
and actually layer the information
between the words. by the 124 boundaries
they probably have some layer of their
network that can be done in parallel and
have deterministic results. So that is
why it's not just important to go read
the docs but just to understand that
there's some architecture decision that
everyone implementing these models is
going to make that dramatically changes
how fast this works and some of you
might be wondering why is it so much
smaller in opus versus haiku one
intuition I could have I don't know
can't guarantee it is that it's possible
that these haiku models use a different
token vocabulary that is much smaller
than the original models therefore
they're able to compress it better or
these These might be uh these might be
using float 16 instead of float 32 or
float 64. So they can comp double
compress it along the way in terms of
how much data they can stuff into the
same amount of comput computational
unit. But I think the point stands is
that there's some computation in every
uh LLM that can be cached to some degree
of it and that the amount of degree that
can be done is based on how much
similarity you have and how big of an
input space you have that is changing.
But what that is to say is that if you
are constantly running a chat thread and
you're dynamically changing the system
message all the time somewhere in here,
you're basic basically breaking the
entire KV cache every single time. That
means you're having to recomputee all
the work always and you can't take any
benefit of the caching system. That
means
>> so just just to make this a little more
concrete um can I like just draw a
little bit more? So like let's say you
have your your system prompt here.
>> Yeah.
uh system prompt and then you have your
tools are technically like end up part
of the system prompt but I'll just put
them separately. The idea would be like
if at some point you wanted to tell the
agent like okay based on some decision
that's happening way over way over on
the right here uh we want to make sure
that the tool set is like only
browserbased tools or whatever it is.
>> You've basically you're going to get a
slower iteration speed on the max token
that gets generated.
>> Yeah. So when you change this, you
completely if you just like even if
you're just removing stuff, when you
change things, you completely kill the
cache. And so this has to be recomputed
from scratch, which is going to be way
slower and also like four times the
cost.
>> Exactly. There's another subtle thing
that probably isn't even obvious here.
Almost everyone I know that's doing some
sort of chatbot will say like date
in here in their system prompt
>> and that
>> that's killing the KV cache for no
reason. You're literally just hurting
the cash every single time.
>> I mean, if you include the time, right?
If you just put the date, it might be
okay, right?
>> Yes. If you're putting the date, sorry,
I should you are correct on that.
There's some time resolution that you're
definitely killing the KB cache. But
even if you don't include the date, if
you have a longunning thread, like last
time we talked about DRM that was coming
through from that uh last time, the
problem with DRM is it's a long process
>> decaying resolution memory. There's like
the context engineering for a model that
can remember stuff that happened months
ago.
>> Exactly.
>> Not a model, but an agent.
>> But in that case, today's date is going
to break the KV cache all the time.
You're just going to be slower for the
entire workload that's happening. It's
generally always going to be good to put
the dynamic stuff of your system as late
as possible. That means if you have a
giant chat thread that you're running
on, it might actually be if you want
like the best performance.
Why is why can't I not draw a rectangle?
it's probably going to be better for you
to have system prompt or your chat
messages and then your like dynamic
variables at the very end because then
as your chat message grows, you're
actually going to have the ability to KV
cache a chat history as well along with
everything else. So it's better to say
today's date at the very end of this
rather than putting it anywhere
beforehand even at the end of the system
message.
I don't know if these kinds of things I
see
>> align with what
>> this is.
>> So I imagine you're going to go to the
point of like oh if you really want to
dynamically change the tools and you
don't want to think about what we're
about to go to which is like using the
like log probabilities and like zeroing
things out to remove them from the from
the tool set that you could change your
tools and put the tools at the end of
the context window instead of at the
beginning.
>> Exactly. So if you're not if same thing
with the tool set like if you want to
dynamically change your tools you got to
put them at the bottom. If you put them
at the top you are just shooting
yourself in the foot in this system. You
will just get slower API calls more
expensive API calls with no real benefit
that you're really having. There's a
secondary benefit that you get for free
um which is at the very very end if you
put things down here the model is just
likely to pay more attention to it. So
anything that is actually relevant and
highly dynamic, it's way easier to
guarantee that the model won't
accidentally forget it because it has
recency bias in general. So question
like application of that um and I think
that's this is maybe also in the paper
and like I've actually like was doing
some more like reverse engineering of
cloud code with a proxy the other day
trying to figure out what the to-do tool
does and like what I would think would
be hey once you write to the to-dos the
system will occasionally reingject the
list of to-dos near the end of the
context window and say hey by the way
here's what you said you were going to
be working on and so you force the
attention to be on that stuff rather
than like hoping that claude will
remember it did that 15 turns ago.
>> Exactly. And that's kind of what one of
the steps down here talks about. Oh,
bump dashing doesn't really matter. Uh
in the manus paper where they release
some of the same stuff which is
>> where is this?
Where's the repetition one? Oh,
repetitation. So the whole point of this
is saying the same thing.
>> Oh yeah, this is it.
>> Simply just stacking stuff all the way
down. Eventually, your information will
get lost. It's not a just like with a
normal human, if you gave them a giant
to-do list of everything to do and you
have one single paper at the very front
that they have to somehow remember, they
will forget steps. We build processes in
place to make sure that stuff gets
duplicated and done more than once in
like high yield scenarios. If I have a
rocket ship that's going to launch, I
will make sure 15 people make check
every single thing because it's just way
less likely that someone will slip up
and make a mistake on all different
things. the model kind of behaves
similarly as well. The more steps you
put on it and as the models get better,
the distance between how long it can
remember and what can remember does go
up. That's undeniably true. But there's
always a distance at which it will never
work as well. So having some repetition
in there is going to make a huge impact
on your output quality for that same
reason. Because what they're really
saying here is like they found that you
can do about 50 tool calls to actually
produce their task, but most models will
basically go off track somewhere in the
middle. really really fast. What we
found in general and like why does this
happen? Well, if you think about how
attention works, you'll often see the
needle in the haststack problem as a
giant benchmark that people go and
evaluate for.
>> Well,
>> terrible benchmark.
>> I don't know about terrible benchmark,
but like in general in English language,
it makes sense that words near each
other have way more impact than words
far away from each other. It's just the
any sort of data set that you're going
to go train on is always going to have
that the sentence I said at the very
beginning of this uh talk matters way
less than the sentence I just said two
minutes ago and that's the whole point
cont
>> well it matters way less to what you're
about to say next
>> yes sorry yes exactly and that's the
same thing the model is going through
the thing that I want to produce over
here is way way more likely to be
related to something that I'm linking
over here. I don't know how to connect
those than it is to be something I'm
linking over here. Now, that it's true
that system messages
are special and I do want system message
to be treated differently and that's why
the model trainers are working on
training the model to understand that
better. That system messages do have
impact throughout the entire span of the
conversation. But that's a training task
and we can wait for the models to get
trained to do that better. But we don't
have that guarantee. So the easiest way
to provide the guarantee and just to get
the best results is to again just put
things that are most relevant to what
the user needs to do as close to what it
needs to happen next. So if I need to
complete a new task and I know that the
model just checked off. Let's say I I'm
building clawed code and the model just
finished task one,
I should probably repeat the task list
again, assuming I'm using a very dumb
model to say this is the task, which
task should you do next? it's just going
to work better than just having the task
at the top saying I completed task one
now what do I do next because the
distance is just further and in that
case I happen to know exactly what needs
to happen which is I need to make
progress on a task list so it's easy for
me to manually inject that but the more
I can do that sort of behavior the more
um consistency I'll get out of my model
outputs
>> and this this just feels like another
recitation of kind of that same theme of
Like, yeah, you could just go back and
forth with the model forever and use the
default like tool call tool tool call
tool call context window, but if it lets
you push your accuracy by 5% or your
speed or your cache efficiency by 5%,
then why not engineer the thing to be as
good as possible?
>> Exactly. Exactly.
Um, there's two questions really fast
and I want to make sure we talk about
them before we go too deep. Um,
>> oh, sorry. I know I'm supposed to be on
question duty. If you have users using
the same models, how will this cache be
h how this cache will be preserved
between the same user calls? Well, the
way that the model providers do this,
the caching is not something you own
unless you're actually running it on
inference. If you do, then you can
control how long the cache runs. The
model bas the model providers basically
compute some of this work ahead of time
and they just save it into like some
data structure, probably a Reddit cache
or something. I have no idea what they
use under the hood and they just say,
"Hey, if we get the sequence of tokens
again, just pull this data out." It's
almost independent
of your user message because uh Dexter
says this all the time. The only thing
that impacts the model is actually like
tokens in tokens out. So like the fact
that it's a user doesn't really matter.
The model doesn't know that. OpenAI
anthropic don't need to know that as
well. And that's how they kind of um
manage this. Hopefully
>> I think in general most of them will not
preserve the same cache between like
technically if it's content addressable
then like the the hash of the content
will always be the hash of the content.
So you're not leaking you know
precomputed attention between users but
like I think technically people still do
segment it out where it's like hey
you're never going to use the cache from
another user. Yeah, I assume that they
did it. Um
I assume that they did it uh because of
uh oh Eugene I yes that is also true.
The model also has its own cache that
computes stuff because of the
architecture. I'm assuming the caching
the model providers are doing are
slightly different. I think that also
helps quite a lot. The actual inference
time is also faster if you have repeated
tokens. Maybe that is what the paper is
talking about and I misinterpreted that.
Um, but really quickly, I suspect the
model providers don't do the caching
storage per on a across user bases
because they need to have TTLs and those
TTLs are really based on your personal
usage, not on anyone else's. Um, raycast
is a fantastic way to test this out
quickly and locally. Can you introduce
you can introduce dynamic variables? Is
there something else you would use for
the similar purposes? I don't know about
something myself, Jensen. Um,
>> I was just thinking about like a quick
snippet copy paste tool. I don't know if
you store prompts in anything else or if
you have a local thing that you guys
use. I have my own other setup myself
including that. So, just curious.
>> I don't have anything, Dex.
>> Yeah. No, I mean I think I think part of
it is like this is this is a lot more
about like building like this this is
more applicable to like building
software that interacts with models than
for like how you prompt them.
>> Yeah. Yeah. No, I I get that. Um, but I
guess as I iterate, I still test things
locally before I like would put them
into what I'm actually going to use. I
don't know if that makes sense in the
way I'm thinking of it, but
uh if I'm iterating on a prompt
essentially or a structure or workflow
that I'm going to be implementing
through a series of orchestrating
agents, I will iterate on each part of
that separately
through using some sort of way to
iterate on the snippet. basically. And
>> I mean, Vibbop's got a lot of opinions
on how to iterate on prompt snippets.
Maybe we'll get
>> So that's I guess that's where I my
mind's at right now. So sidetracked.
>> I would say like none of this none of
the stuff that we're talking about today
really matters for prompt iteration
speed. That that really doesn't matter.
This only matters for like you have a
prompt, it's working, but you want to
make that thing work faster and better.
How do you go do that?
Cool. Um how should how do we know the
tlet is or isn't cached? uh should there
shouldn't this be managed as it changes?
Yes. Uh to some degree, but really
there's only one way to know that it's
cached, which is if the model provider
tells you that. If they don't actually
give you that information, you can't
possibly know. So, it really depends on
the inference provider.
>> I mean, you can kind of proxy it because
of latency, [clears throat] but not
really definitively.
>> See, this is why me and Vibbove work
well together is he's really good at
just talking through my random questions
and finishing his point. So, please keep
doing that. Um question though like are
you gonna show us today how to use a a
LM client to actually look at the
responses and see the like caching to
like the caching like headers that come
back like I I think that would be super
super valuable to like untangle like the
whether or whatever untangle the
response and see like hey look let's
change the end of it and see how many
cache tokens we got versus changing the
beginning and see that it blows the
cash.
>> Yeah that should be possible. Uh Eugene
had a really good point actually and I
realized I actually had totally missed
this which is there's actually two types
of caching that are going on here which
is one caching done by the actual model
providers in terms of helping with
encoder decoder blocks and then the
actual transformer architecture also
allows you to do another type of cache
in there. Um
I think I can pull this up
architecture. Let's see if I can put up
there's a very famous image.
I put up but basically
uh let's see if I can find this.
Basically a lot of the actual uh nodes
in here a lot of the math can also be
precomputed along the way at any point
in the way. The part that I was talking
about was actually this part which is
the encoder node of the uh transformer
can actually be precomputed based of the
actual um uh input tokens that are going
in and this whole layer can almost be
cached because it's not really dependent
on the output probabilities and these
are going to be able to take some
advantage of that. The second half of
this that Eugene is talking about is
also the K there's a KV cache in the
actual model like matrix multiplication
areas and those can also uh dramatically
improve the amount of computation
throughput you can get out of the actual
transform architecture that may be
actually what the paper is talking about
Eugene I may have missed that
>> yeah I think it is about the cache
inside the model
>> yes um so in that case it's still the
principle is still the same
>> everything's the same except nothing's
going into reddice I probably is the the
key detail.
>> Yes. Well, no, that one's cutting down
on the actual math that it has to go do.
But the main difference is the the
premise is still the same. The number of
continuity tokens you have dramatically
changes the amount of caching that
you're going to get. Anytime you go
change the continuity of the tokens, the
more likely you are going to be to break
the cache at any point and get a miss on
the cache.
Um, how do I how do I eval if my updated
context handling uh will
improve the quality? Um, I think we've
had a couple talks on evals. It's
actually very annoying to do evals and
it's very frustrating, but I think the
first step to do evals is just to define
quality to some degree and what it
means. Understand what is clearly good,
what is clearly bad, what is mostly
good, mostly bad, and then just like buy
be valid in the beginning. And once you
have a better understanding of that
system, then you can go ahead and
actually make these trade-offs. The only
reason that the likely can do this work
or any engineering team can do this work
is because they first have to go ahead
and say this is good and this is bad.
The eval are useless.
>> And I'd say like most of the stuff we
talk about about eval here is about
quality of the outputs in terms of like
accuracy, hostations, using the right
context, things like that. um the
quality improvements that we're getting
here because like at the end of the day
whether you cash it or not it's the same
tokens in which means your chance of
getting the right tokens out is probably
about the same. Um so this is a really
interesting kind of category of eval
talked as much about which is like how
do you evaluate the performance not in
terms of accuracy but in terms of uh
speed and cost.
>> Yeah. Um I think VJ asked an interesting
question. I guess it's Rajes point out a
different thing. If the model weights
are the same, everything is new, how do
you actually get caching? Um, it's
really hard to describe how the math on
a GPU gets cached, but you can do
caching on there. Uh, you should take my
word for it. There's a beautiful video
made by um, if any of you are interested
how this is a this is probably one of
the best videos I've ever seen.
>> Hey everyone, I'm by
>> I'm sorry. I I every time I pull up the
YouTube channel, I I hear I hear you
introducing
>> I'll post the video on here. There's
like a I think uh there's like a
90-minute video that I watched that
actually talked about how deepseek
actually works under the hood and talks
about the math behind it. Um I think
it's actually this one by
>> this one of the best ones I've ever
seen. It will describe it. It'll
probably teach you more about um
anything you could see. I wish I could
make [laughter]
>> John best video I ever seen pulls up
video of self
>> and it'll talk to you about like how
it's possible to get way better
throughput than anyone else can on the
same math that everyone else is doing.
>> Um
context caching in our app thesis code
is open source if anyone Okay, cool.
There's just an example. If Duck has an
example, then definitely share it, Doug.
And we'd love to have people go be able
to see it.
>> Yeah, drop it in the chat.
>> VJ, we've got a question. We'll take
that and then we'll go to the next part
of the system after that.
>> So if I understood this correctly, uh
for example, let's say our uh model has
an input uh window of 256k tokens and
we're trying to uh let's say take
advantage of that entire context window.
So essentially what you're saying is
whatever we input in that 256k context
uh as much as possible
uh that string should be uh unchanging
or let's say static it should be the
same in next iteration so that you can
get the next token quicker and the end
of that uh input context will probably
be varying per call. So I think the next
step would be to understand how agents
are iterating between different calls
and see what is changing what is not
changing in what we are sending the LLM
and sort of restructure that entire
input uh sequence. Is that is that is
that the next step like is am I thinking
about this correctly? I
>> I think maybe I just maybe I didn't
understand all the words you said
perfectly and it's probably because I
woke up at 4 a.m.
>> Okay, let me simplify it. So we are
sending tokens to the LLM.
>> Yes.
>> The sequence of tokens as much as it is
unchanged the faster we get a response.
>> Yes.
>> Therefore our next step would obviously
be to understand uh a couple of
iterations of what we are sending the
LLM see what is changing what is not
changing and try to restructure that.
Correct.
>> Yes. Exactly. There's
>> there are caveats though in terms of
actual implementation details here that
matter. If you own the model yourself
and you're doing inference, it's a very
different game than if you're actually
using the existing inference providers.
So for example, Enthropic lets you
actually control cache control with this
cache control block. And where you put
it dramatically matters because if you
put at the very beginning of a system,
if you put it your system message, it
will dramatically change the throughput
that you are personally able to get. If
you have a really long chat thread and
you just put it at the beginning of a
chat thread and you don't break apart
your chat threads manually, you're going
to get worse hits. There's just nothing
you can do about that because your chat
thread is basically you put you put a
cache control block on the first user
message and then you in the same chat
control block you put another user
message. It's just a cache miss. It's a
guaranteed cache miss. You can't
actually do anything about that.
So every time you're not reconstructing
the prompt in the same way as close to
possible, you are basically getting a
miss. Gemini, I think I think the way
OpenAI does caching is opaque. So what
that means is I I think they give you
almost no information on how caching
works. But I think they actually what
they do but
>> it's like less control, but they kind of
just try to do it for you. This is a lot
of them just like do a prefix and try to
guess how to do it. I didn't need
actually know this,
>> but now they added like a prompt cache
key. So, it's like
>> prompt cache. And the reason that they
do this, I'm certain uh replace the
user. I don't know what this is, but I'm
pretty certain that the reason they do
this is people just wanted more control
because if you're able to have access to
this and you can control this, you can
just get better hits all the time. Um,
but it is important to go read this
stuff. And the only way you can actually
know if you're hitting this is just by
looking at the usage. There's no other
way to really know
um along unless you own the inference
and most people don't own inference as
far as I know u and most people probably
shouldn't own inference as well. Uh,
Gemini is probably the most flexible
thing I have seen for how they cache and
Eugene is right on that, which is if you
actually go look into how to get caches,
like you do a you do some crap to go
write this code, but the trade-off of
doing this crap is you do get to go get
complete control over what it's doing
and you get to go tell it this and that
helps you as a developer, but it also
hurts you because you have to go build
this stuff yourself.
Um, you also have to manage the TTL and
everything automatically. So, there's
always a trade-off in how much
engineering effort you want to put in
versus what you want to do manually. Uh,
what you want to do automatically. And
generally, if you do something manually,
you will always get better throughput if
you know what you're doing than someone
that does it automatically. But someone
that does it automatically will always
get better than someone that doesn't
know what they're doing manually
because if you blow the cache up time,
it'll be worse.
>> So,
>> okay. So, if you know if you know what
you're doing, use the cache keys. If you
don't, hope for the prefix things. But
don't try to mess with the cache keys if
you don't if you're not willing to go
learn how these systems work.
>> Exactly. And lastly, if you're not act
and if you don't have the time to go
learn how they work, it's not a matter
of like you don't want to. Sometimes you
just don't have the time. We're all
bouncing a lot of things at once. Um but
what comes down to is if your cache
isn't working, you now know why it isn't
working. It's because your prefix key is
not continuous and it's breaking somehow
when whatever system you're using to
break it, you're getting a cache miss
for that reason.
Um, I think the next thing I want to
talk about
is actually talking about this one. The
we talked about recitation a little bit.
So like recite your systems. Think about
what makes sense in your workflows to
recite this. And it can do all sorts of
different things. So for example in the
example that they gave over here what
they're showing in their visual is hey
instead of producing context one and
doing this what I will say is before
even producing action for I will inject
an objective into the statement and now
I can go and produce objective 4. So
there's different ways to go repeat
yourself in the prompt. There's one is
just add it to the very end. One is take
your existing prompt and go inject it
somewhere else in my history. And yes,
this is kind of contradictory to what we
just talked about about breaking the
cache key, but you're doing this
deliberately because you're trying to
get accuracy. So you're like, "Okay,
cool. I will lose the cache on this part
of my prompt. I will still preserve the
cache on everything up until here, but I
will do that in favor of getting
slightly better accuracy and helping the
model understand what's going on."
And the premise here is this objective.
It may be obvious to the model at this
point that action three was best. But
when it's making action four, the model
might forget that because of this
objective, action three was selected
here. So I'm repeating that here's
objectives and this is why you picked
action three. Now pick action four. I
can also just say
>> go ahead.
>> Has anyone ever implemented this like
kind of deterministic injection of a
to-do list into the context window as
it's going?
>> I would be surprised if cloud code
doesn't do something like this. That's
what I'm I'm messing with that idea
right now is what I
>> Cool.
>> Yeah. doing.
>> Um, so this one I think is really
straightforward and easy to iterate on.
So if you're finding that you have
really really long tool call sequences
and they're diverting from or drifting
from the main action, just like add some
repetition there and you might just get
free throughput uh without having to do
much work. And I think that's that's the
cool thing about this trick. This is
almost no effort.
Um, I want to talk about this. This is
something that we've talked about a lot,
which is a lot of times when in an agent
loop, it'll try and go do many things
and then it will go ahead and go correct
things along the way.
And in this case, I think what they
found is they found in their scenario
keeping if they're running two things in
parallel, getting all the predictions,
actually having the incorrect stuff
helps them. I would just go experiment
and try this. What we have found is
having the incorrect stuff hurts in some
scenarios, but it's possible in their
use case because they're running like on
average at least 50 tool calls that
perhaps having incorrect sequences helps
the model correct itself and not repeat
the same behavior in the case of very
repetitive actions. Eugene, you
>> funny because this is this is contrary
to advice we give a lot, which is like
be smart about sometimes pulling those
out because it becomes very noisy.
>> Yeah, Eugene, you've got a question.
>> Yeah, I got a question. Um yeah, I think
this one on the incorrect observations
is quite intuitive to me. One thing
that's also not so intuitive to me is
the tool call. Do you just store do you
just return to the main model, the main
agent, the output of the tool call or do
you also keep the tool call itself?
So I have different opinions on this and
I think the thing that they're saying
here is so I found when I was reading
this is like I think the reason that
they're seeing this it's that often
having a stack trace helps even a
developer debug the problem and I think
what they're I think the re because this
feels very wrong to me as well but I
think what's happening is manis has a
very broad scope of what it's trying to
do so many times a model will divert and
not do the right thing and in that
scenario assuming that it has to do that
thing again or some it's somewhat
related to the final goal and it might
have to repeat that task again. it's
more likely that the model will get it
right the first time around. If we can
kind of look at it stack trace and say
what did it take to get to the final
correct answer.
That said, I'm not actually yet
convinced that the best way to represent
the tool calls are actually the tool
calling systems that people have. I
think there's a lot more
>> really you think there's a better way to
represent tool calling.
>> Well, I don't know if that's sarcastic
or not, but like even [laughter]
there's like a interesting thing. I'm
teeing you up, man.
uh that I thought was really
interesting. Uh wrong discord
where sorry I'm usually on a desktop
monitor when I'm doing this and it's a
little bit more um showcase. I thought
this was a fantastic thread here that
really helped me understand uh kind of
some of the implications of some of this
stuff. So Pashant who is one of the
people that been playing on both DSP and
BAML learned something really
interesting. uh what he did was he
changed how DSPI represents their prompt
format uh to be away from JSON schema
and go more into like the BAML way of
doing it. And what was really
interesting is just a simple way of
changing how you represent the tool call
for every single model by default was
just better than JSON schema.
But when you add the two together, it
got even better. And I think that goes
into what Eugene is asking is like
what's the best way to represent tool
call? To be completely honest, I don't
[ __ ] know. I have no opinions on
this. But I think in general simplicity
is best. So if you have a thing where
you're generating a bunch of like Luma
URLs, don't put UU IDs into the uh don't
put UU IDs into the
uh into the prompt. It's just going to
hurt even if tool call generates one.
Like replace that out. We have a thing
in our chatbot uh that we made recently
and I I thought it was kind of funny
that and we talk about this stuff all
the time but like if you ask it like um
how do I do this thing like how do I
build a super complex agent?
What I found really funny in here is one
of our uh someone on my team built this
and I've tried my best not to influence
anyone on the team in any meaningful
way. Okay, I want them to discover their
own agent assigned decisions, which is
how do I get help? How do I get help?
Sorry. Which was when they actually put
our Discord link in here, they
originally did this, but this thing was
inconsistent and they had to reprompt it
to actually go ahead and actually change
the boundaryml.com/isord.
In this case, this one was fine because
it actually pulled this page as context
info and fed that into there. So, it was
able to do regurgitation. But when you
left on the system prompt as the main
way of getting help, it didn't work. So
they actually changed
>> I'm sorry. This is the you said the
problem is because this is some weird
long string token that's hard for the
model to remember.
>> And in this case, what they're doing,
they're actually pruning it out and
injecting this page in as the only
contact information page. So it's really
easy for it to regurgitate. It's a
pretty beefy model.
>> But what they found is we actually made
a link called boundarymail.com/isord
and putting this in the system prompt
works almost all the time.
All right. It's the same context. So
it's like just thinking about how to
make these systems work in terms of tool
calls is I don't really know what the
best answer is. But the better you can
do to get towards simplicity in general,
the way more throughput you will get.
Yeah, exactly. Random hashes are just
not good. Like the model is just never
going to be good at that. And I think
it's the same thing here. Like I think
in their scenario kind of works, but I
would just eval this for your own use
case. I suspect if you have a simple
task and it did it wrong twice,
you'll probably get better by just
giving it the right output. If you're
using a smaller model, you probably
don't want to give a smaller model the
entire stack trace because a smaller
model is just going to get lost in the
sauce. If you have a bigger model, you
can be more you're more it's more
forgiving in general for all of this
information. So trying to figure out
exactly what you have to do is both a
parameterization of the problem space
you're working in and the model you're
using. And it's like a fine art of
figuring out what that is exactly.
But the fact that this works for them,
like to me, this slightly changed my
perspective of being completely rigid on
only using observation 2B in the final
prompt. Now, what I do,
>> Go ahead.
>> Sorry. Go ahead. No, finish your
thought.
>> Well, what I was going to say is next
time I have a really hard problem and I
use GD5, for example, I'll probably toss
an entire stack trace and just see how
well it does because it's possible that
models have changed. Last time I built
this opinion was based off of like the
GP40 models
>> and perhaps the models are different
now. And it's good for me to be aware of
that and like be open to changing my own
perspectives.
>> Interesting. I mean, so this is
interesting. It doesn't say so it's like
error recovery, but I'm not it's not
clear as saying like um like this
picture says, hey, like use the
observation to get it to get it
correctly, right? Or use the thing to
get it to get correctly the first time.
But it doesn't seem to have an opinion
on like okay if you have four errors and
then you get it right that you should
clear out those four errors before you
proceed.
>> Yeah. Yeah. It's how they I think what
they're saying is typically many people
never store this information.
>> I think what they're making a case for
is hey consider storing the information
sometimes it might help.
>> Yeah. This is uh factor nine of 12
factor agents is like be thoughtful
about it but yeah tell the model what it
did wrong because it will probably fix
it. Um, and the models are getting way
better. So like the stack traces are
likely more likely to help, especially
as the stuff gets bigger and bigger in
terms of context windows and how well
models perform over long form context.
Um, that said, same thing we talked
about here. Proximity to the cache
matters. Proximity to the observation.
Oh, where did it go? Proximity to the
observations matter. Where? I don't know
where it went. That image, the
repetition one. Proximity to the
observations matter. So like if you make
it too big, you'll probably get loss of
performance at some point for your task.
Um let's talk about prompting. I say
this all the time. Don't do fot
prompting. The reason fot prompting is
bad is for the same reason that we say
all the time, which is you're most
people don't do fot prompting correctly.
You're almost most likely going to bias
the model away towards your fshot
example rather than help it understand
what it's actually meant to do. Well,
and literally building an agent is fshot
prompting. Like everything in your past
context window becomes like influences
the next step. And so if the model
starts like starts a task and launches a
sub agent for the rest of that
conversation, the model will be more
likely to launch a sub agent. And so
like you have to really like understand
and this is why we always say like use
clear rather than resteer. If the model
like starts doing something weird in
your agentic chat, whatever system it
is. Obviously, I care a lot about coding
agents, but like this is true for
everything is like the model starts
going about it in the wrong way, you are
much better off starting with a fresh
context and adding two sentences of
steering or two words of steering, by
the way, don't do this than you are to
be like, stop, do it a different way.
And then because then your prompt is
like your context window says system
prompt, user message, model tried this,
user resteered it. And so you're more
likely for the model to like expect that
the conversation continues as model
tries a bad thing, user resteers, model
tries a bad like you you're telling the
model it's okay to make a mistake and
then get corrected. When what you really
want is the model to think, okay, cool.
I made the right decision. I made the
right decision. I made the right
decision. That's how you craft like
really good agentic context as you go.
>> Also contextual. Just remember undo is a
pretty complex action. The fact that we
can do command Z is nice on a computer,
but it's actually really hard to undo
sequences of actions. And that's why
many apps, ma, most SAS apps you use
don't build command Z. It's really
freaking hard to command Z a lot of
actions. Uh, and the model is just going
to have a hard time too. Uh, Photoshop,
for example, will just eventually forget
that you have you you're past a certain
state. It'll just say you can't undo
past this point. Same thing. Um, in
terms of fot examples, there are ways to
do it correctly. It's just that you have
to be really thoughtful about it. In
this case, if I have a class object
where I want product to mean only people
that actually actively write code, then
someone that's listed as director of
engine team, I can just write a small
thing in here that says because they
don't code themselves category product.
And now the model can kind of this is
perfectly evident that this is an
example to the model. It's I'm not
trying to trick it. I'm not trying to do
anything. It's just like this one is an
example very clearly. I use dot dot dot
to simplify that. I'm showing the schema
without showing the full schema. The
model cannot possibly confuse Vivov
Gupta as that person because I mean the
really really dumb model can but modern
models are just not going to have that
problem. So if you're going to do
fuchsia prompting be clever about it
think about what you're really trying to
have the fat example explain to the
model and only put the minimum number of
tokens you need to explain that concept
itself
>> and not just number of tokens but like
meaning of tokens right like that dot
dot token means placeholder to the
model.
>> Exactly. Yeah. And to almost anyone else
reading it. It's same thing same with
dynamic fshot prompting. Sometimes you
might want to put few shots that are
actually similar to your example.
Sometimes you might want to pick few
shots because they're completely the
opposite of your example. And sometimes
you might want to pick few shots that
are unrelated to your example. Let's say
you're in a healthcare setting and
you're processing doctor patient
conversations.
You probably don't want to talk about
like um I don't know like uh uh like leg
fractures. If you're talking very
commonly if the person currently has a
leg fracture, that's just going to mess
up the accuracy of the system. No matter
what you do, you probably don't want to
put the person's name as the same name
as your patient in your system. You
probably don't want the doctor's name to
be the same. Probably don't want the
hospital name to be the same. You
probably don't want to confuse it with
dates in case of continuity of any kind.
So, finding this sort of stuff out and
picking the right fat example can be
good, but as you're you're probably
figuring this out, it's a lot of work to
be fought prompting correctly. So, most
people are better off not doing it
rather than doing it.
Uh, let's go on to the next topic.
Unless there's more, feel free to keep
typing questions in the chat. U if you
have any
>> um
>> um we might have to do a follow-up
session and do the the coding side
because I don't know if we're gonna have
time.
>> Yes,
>> I really I really want to see an example
of how to look at the B responses and u
>> Okay, cool.
>> Um I think I did want to talk about all
these topics because I thought they were
really really interesting. I think the
most last one that I thought is worth
actually we'll talk about this one first
because it's really easy. Um this what I
read is very much about context
compression at least the way I
interpreted this one which wasn't about
like use the file system in the context
like that's one way to do it but what I
was hearing was instead of putting in
the entire chunk all the time at all
points
see if you can break down the system and
only put in the least amount of system
that's uh least amount of context that's
relevant. So for example, if every uh
and like I think that's the whole point,
everything is meant to be restoable. The
idea is that if you're having a whole
website here, instead of actually
putting the website over here, just put
the URL over here and replace the
original observation action two with
just the URL and say from this URL, I
got this action. From this URL, I got
this action. From this URL, I got this
action. And then
>> Oh, I see. So the model the model may
even load the thing into context and
then you choose the next action and then
you stitch the actual content back you
pull it out of the context window so
that like it can be restored later it
can be pulled back in but it's not by
default present.
>> Exactly. And you can even tell this is a
restorable tool, restore data blob,
restore with this key
>> and the model can then if it needs to
call the restore action. And yes, it
increases the number of tools that you
have to make to call your system, but it
dramatically makes your context window
way more efficient because most of the
time, for example, for a coding agent,
imagine trying to keep every single file
the model had to edit in the context and
all the edits are made in the context.
It's kind of useless. like once it's
made a file edit, I can kind of compress
it and say, "I'm done with this file.
The user is happy and it works. Here's a
summary of what the file, what changes I
made,
but keeping the actual code that it
generated is kind of useless for that
kind of task." And then when I tell the
model, hey, actually that file is wrong,
then it can load the load action to load
the file again, reread it, and go do the
work. And there's a trade-off here
between how many tool calls it takes
versus how accurate the system is versus
how uh versus how like u how big of a
context window I have.
But
if you don't make this a possibility,
then you kind of live in this world
where you have to live in big context
land. And then you're just hoping that
GBT26 has a 20 million token window. And
like maybe it will, but like
I really don't want to work in a world
where like every computer needs to have
50 terabytes of RAM or else it's
useless. Like that that's just a sad
world to have to live in. And also like
phones.
Uh I would like stuff to work on my
phone without needing to go uh go into
this. Duck asked a question. How does it
work with KV caching? Well, it really
depends if your system I think an
important thing to notice about KV
caches and like people overindex on this
sometimes and I I know I I was trying to
explain it so perhaps that was implying
this but look KV caches don't caching
and latency doesn't matter for small
stuff. If most of your chat messages in
your app or agentic loops are like one
or two system calls long, don't do any
of this crap. It is not worth it. Just
make your system work. This stuff only
matters for stuff that is going to run
for a while. If your tasks are taking
like a minute to run, uh yes, then KB
cache matters. But in that case, if your
task is taking a minute to run because
it's calling like 50 different tool
calls, you'll probably get way better KV
cache optimization simply by changing
the observations in this way as well
where like now I get a KV cache here and
only if I load in a new observation do I
break the KV cache because then I'm
going to load observation one and then
compress it into this format. So now
this thing becomes compressed. But what
I can do here is I can design an
algorithm here that's pretty
straightforward that goes ahead and
says, "Hey, after about 15 observations,
I always compress the oldest one." So
yes, I broke my KV cache, but at any
given time, all my previous context is
always going to be similar and and I'll
basically force the model to reload it
because this once it's compressed is
never reloaded ever again. So this
becomes stable. This basically
stabilizes over time. Does that answer
the question, Doug? [clears throat]
>> Perfect. Um,
and then the debate of showing tool
calls and what to output. Yeah.
>> Yeah, I think you got it perfectly,
Doug. Yeah, exactly. Once it once it
gets the next step and it knows what to
do, then it can do it. And I think this
is also like when people do there's like
certain like compaction strategies that
you can do. Like anthropic talks about
micro compaction which is like pulling
at least like the tool calls out
automatically but it's really hard to do
this in a general purpose way which is
what makes this paper so impressive is
like they've done this for a general
purpose agent. If you're building an
agent for a very specific thing you can
optimize the heck out of it for that one
use case and you know exactly like I
know for sure if a model reads this type
of medical document it's and it once it
makes the decision it never needs to do
it again. Or you can say, okay, once the
model reads in and picks the next thing,
I need to pass it to another model to
summarize the document. Put that in
instead of the whole content and like do
your own like deterministic compaction
based on what types of things are being
pulled into the context.
>> Exactly. Now I want to talk about the
last part that I thought was super super
uh innovative and really changed my
perspective a little bit on some things
as well, which is around how to call
work. So we talked about the KB cache,
we talked about how like having
continuity and not breaking continuity
matters. So, we talked I think one easy
way to go fix this is you can take your
tool calls and simply put them always
guarantee put them at the end of your
context window and now you always have
some amount of caching that you get for
free. But what if you did put them at
the top? Well, many times if you're
building an agent, you'll want to
invalidate and change your tools
dynamically.
That is 100% of the time going to break
your KV cache and you will just get
slower latency all the way through. This
was what the the swarm like the original
iteration of like the open AI swarms
framework or whatever their way of doing
multi-agent was to take the same context
window patch it to a different agent
which had a different system message and
a different set of tools.
>> Exactly. And like it just doesn't really
work. But what they end up doing here
that I thought thought was really
fascinating is instead of actually
giving you these tools, they actually
leave the tools in there. And what they
do is they modify
uh let me change let me delete they
modify a part of the system that I think
most people don't think about which is
let me open up the openi docs because I
think that's it's going to show
openai
responses
API. Okay, cool. Uh they modify the
logits coming out of it.
There you go. And you can basically
invalidate certain tokens as being valid
out of the model. So I don't actually
know how you modify the function calling
tokens. I can go look into that because
it sounds like I don't know if Openack
gives you those, but if you own the
model, you can definitely do this. But
the premise is
uh there we go. The premise is like what
the heck is function calling doing? And
we need to go understand that briefly to
really be able to and appreciate this
technique. So what function calling does
is function calling teaches a model
about a special token called use tool
and the model outputs a token that says
I'm going to output a tool and once it
decides to do that token the model
providers then restrict the model to
only pick tokens that match the tool
specification that you have provided. So
>> is this constrained is this constrained
decoding or is this still just the base
like JSON mode? This is
it. So the base JSON mode does that
which is it basically takes it basically
forces the model to only output
grammarss that are valid uh JSON.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
>> Constraint decoding constraint
generation or decoding whatever you want
to call it is basically the more general
form of that where instead of taking the
JSON grammar you can basically provide
it the grammar of your choice.
>> Any reax and that just zeros out all of
the log probabilities for anything that
doesn't match your reax. Right.
>> Exactly. So if I go back to the
whiteboard,
what this is doing is this is basically
saying like even though the model has a
really high probability for it, I'll
vote this as zero because it doesn't
match the reax of what's allowed. So
only the only the reax is the valid
consideration and then I pick the best
token from the valid reax. Now the
problem that you will run into with this
is sorry I have a lot of tabs open
today.
>> Yeah, we talked about this a lot this
concept in cracking the prompting
interview, right? That was the one.
Yeah,
>> we talked about like how to get AI to
write better code by allowing it to
write things that might not necessarily
be valid JSON but are like closer to the
way that the model has been trained to
write code which is by like reading code
not as snippets and JSON strings.
>> The function calling system does
basically this. It basically says
instead of having the model always
follow the grammar, it says hey you will
emit a special token that says you want
to take an action and then I will force
you to follow the grammar. So at that
point the model is basically deciding to
some degree and can be taught when it
should follow the grammar that it's
given. And now open has a new thing
which I think is really really good for
everyone which is they've allowed you to
do function calling without a grammar or
with a custom grammar. So now you can
basically let the model say I want to
use an action and then let it free form
output whatever it wants. But what the
manus paper uh article talks about is
that when it actually picks the use tool
action at that point the model is now
going to pick a special token. It's
going to pick a certain uh uh
>> the first thing that comes out is the
name of the function. Right.
>> Exactly. It's going to have to spit out
the name of the function. Instead of
actually letting the model spit out the
name of the function at that point, you
can
effectively Where'd it go? You can
effectively prevent the model from
picking a certain tool at that point.
and say that
>> by just zeroing the probability that the
name of the function matches like the
basically like forcing only allowing the
to the log props that actually match the
tool set that you want to constrain to.
>> Exactly.
So this is actually a really really good
technique but I'm going to show you and
I thought it's really really clever but
I'm going to show you how naming your
tools in an interesting way can
dramatically change the accuracy of this
technique.
cursor
>> and I'm going to do this with an example
I think in code because it's going to be
a little bit better
>> and just while you're doing that the
question was like when talking about
tool calls are we talking about explicit
tool calling via model providers or are
we also thinking about whatever
structured output techniques we're using
I think tool calling structured output
and function calling um while there are
different flavors of each of them I
think those three words tend to refer to
the same thing some people say like oh
tool calling is only when you use JSON
mode and structured output is can
doesn't even need to use JSON mode. But
again, like I use all three of those
terms interchangeably. Tool calling,
structured output, function calling.
>> They're all the same.
>> Is that accurate?
>> I agree. There's technical
implementation differences that might
have different trade-offs, but they're
all the same. Fundamentally, what you're
doing is trying to constrain with the
model output to some degree in some
manner or form.
>> Well, and and it's the constraint. It's
not even about the constraining. I think
more for me it's more so about we're
going to create something that a
deterministic program can consume. It's
not for a human and it's not for a
model. It's for Python code that I
wrote. And so it has to have some
expected structure that I can turn it
into bytes in memory.
>> Yeah. So let's say I have these three
tools.
Um right uh and these are the tools I
have. Call me, call mom, call Dexter. Um
and let's say I'm operating the mode in
like work mode. In work mode, I want the
tools call Dexter and call me to be
available. In nonwork mode, so like uh I
want the tools call mom and call me to
be available. I'll never call Dexter not
work mode. I don't like hanging out with
him that much. So how [laughter]
well what we're going to do the model
decide I I'll say a statement like uh I
need to talk to someone.
I'm going to go write the statement. In
this case, call me is clearly not a good
tool cuz I want to talk to someone else,
not myself. So, it should call mom or
Dexter. If I give it all the tools as
context, it could really pick any of
them and it's random in work mode.
However, maybe there's another thread in
here that says like I'm at work. So, the
model and there's some information I
have in my program state that allows me
to know that. So, I have some at work
boolean as true as true or false.
If it is true, I basically want to say
like disable
call mom
and I want to go disable call mom at
that point. If I'm going to go do that,
um, sorry, I'm going to turn this off
text.
Uh, that was not correct.
If I'm going to go do that,
>> the model will start generating tokens.
Now the problem with this is the model
may want to generate a token that starts
maybe the token vocabulary makes it so
that the tokens are actually call and
then mom. So the tokens end up being
call and then mom. And over here the
tokens end up being call and then
Dexter.
If the model generates a token call,
even though I've invalidated this, I've
invalidated call mom, the model may have
actually thought it was really important
to call mom and it may be actually
accidentally forced to picking the call
Dexter tool.
>> Forced to call me. [laughter]
>> Yeah, because it doesn't have a choice
because it it produced the word call. Uh
>> with the intent to call mom
>> with the intent to call mom because I'm
at work mode and I've accidentally
disabled the call mom tool. And now the
model thinks it's want to call mom
because all my tools are in the context
window. So even if the model know the
model doesn't know it can't actually
pick call mom. As far as the model knows
it can pick call mom. So now it might
even go do this. It might even start
outputting call m because m was a valid
token as well in my token vocabulary.
And funnily enough the model might not
even end up calling du. It might end up
calling me because in the tok to token
vocabulary we have call we have we
obviously have the letter m we have the
letter me we have the word me we have
the letter mom we probably have the
words mo as well
>> oh okay so the probability for mom might
have been 99% and the probability for m
might have been 1% but because both of
them are moving towards mom those are
the ones that got picked
>> exactly and mo might also be higher so
I've invalided mo and mom because it
doesn't meet the grammar of what's
allowed based on what what tools are
valid. But I still will call M. So I'll
call M. And now I might call M. Well,
what's the next best token? Well,
there's only one valid token that's
available here. I have to call it E. So
now I'll end up calling the call me
tool. And you can see how actually doing
this can actually backfire in certain
ways if you're not careful about how
you're naming your tools.
So you have if you're going to use this
technique, it is important to be able to
understand how these models work and
build an intuition for this on your own.
So then when something fails or doesn't
fail, you can go iterate on this and
make it better.
>> Does that um any questions?
>> Yeah, there questions about that. There
was there's a lot of content in there.
Otherwise, we can move to some of these
questions.
Uh, call me versus call me variable
name. No, that's totally arbitrary, I
think. Um,
>> I'll show you like a um a really fun uh
post by someone.
Uh
oh, that's the wrong thing. Let's not
show my DMs.
>> While you're doing that, Dexporty with
the understanding of tool calling can be
either an explicit tool call or
structured out. pick your flavor. In the
work that you are doing, have you
noticed any difference in Asian
performance when using model provider
tool calling versus pamble structured
output? Basically, home rule tool
calling. Uh I have no stake in this. Uh
but I believe there's a lot of agents
out there that are built with native
tool calling that would be better if
they used the pamel structured output
for some of the reasons we've kind of
touched on here, but other things. Uh
but I
>> I don't I need viob to ship the
benchmark again. When are we getting v2
of your of your tool calling benchmark?
>> Well, Sean showed a small benchmark
already that showed
>> that's truely better.
>> Um but I want to show everyone a clear
example of when this matters. So like in
this case the user was doing some sort
of tool calling with Kimmy K2 model and
they asked the model to output approach
and no matter what they did like around
like 2% of the time Kimmy K2 would
literally just pull out a propra
[laughter] and this is so wild that it
would actually do this and I started
looking into this and eventually I was
like okay well there's prompt
engineering techniques that you can do
to go do this. So they did that and
eventually
>> did they just add an alias to the field?
Well, eventually what I did was I just
wanted to go understand this. I was
like, so what did I do? I dumped out the
tokenizer. I literally took the
tokenizer for the K2 model and I dumped
it out. And lo and behold, approach is
two tokens.
So of course the model that's a dumber
model is going to get this wrong because
at this point it wants to do approach
and then it's like it's just too dumb to
actually do this. So the solution this
user had was they actually found a word
that was a single token and now it
works.
That's so sick.
>> And just like but the point is like if
your tool calling is going to use a
similar technique, you have to
understand that there are trade-offs to
how your tokenizer vocabulary works. And
the bigger the model, the shorter your
context window, the less they matter.
The smaller the model, the longer your
context window, the more they matter.
And knowing that is just key to getting
success over here.
>> Love it.
>> Yeah. Um, and like remember tokenizers
are different for every model. So you
have to like in like this user could
have spent forever trying to prompt
engineer the way the heck out of this
trying to make it work and they did. Um,
and I think Sam and our team tried this
too and I tried a couple techniques and
literally I just at some point I was
like the model is just too stupid.
What's going on? And I had to go and dig
deep. So don't be afraid to go do that.
Just literally run the tokenizer code
and just go see what's happening.
Uh, really really easy hack to go make
this work. any model provider that
doesn't give you the tokenizer, it's
kind of annoying.
Just have the model provider spit back
out the word to you and count the tokens
out of the HTTP request. That's often
what I'll do with like entropic models
because they don't actually give me the
tokenizer. So I'll say,
>> oh, you say, "Hey, just say the word
approach to me and then you look at the
token counts in the raw JSON that comes
back and say, how many tokens was that?"
>> Literally what I do.
>> Okay.
>> Um, and it kind of works.
Um,
yeah, if you're curious about the
benchmarks, uh, I can share them
afterwards, uh, on the email that we
send out, um, if you're interested or in
our Discord you ask, we'll have
Discords.
>> Slava's question real quick. Yeah, we
put all the streams in the GitHub repo.
That's where you can find them. Um,
yeah. Do you want to pull it up?
>> Uh, what is
>> there? It is. So, you can come here. You
can see every every recording we've done
since March. You can see the YouTube.
you can see the code. Um, you can sign
up for the next one.
>> And if all you really
>> about the
>> if all you really want to do is just
watch all the content, we have a
playlist somewhere um that you can find.
And I don't hear my voice again.
>> Uh, but they'll have everything on
there. And then I think we tried to make
a interesting version of this
uh where we actually do this with
Dexter. And you can actually just scroll
through here as well.
>> Oh man. Wait, this is sick.
>> Wait, I want this on human layer.dev,
dev too.
>> I'll send you the code. You can post it
over.
>> Amazing.
>> Um uh do you mind me and then point the
resource try this out locally. The thing
about um we'll try and give you some
sample code to go try this out locally.
But honestly, for most of these
problems, just take any of the problems
that you have that you've already been
working on and just like go look at the
inspect the output elements that are
coming out of these problems. So like
for example,
um let's just write a really quick uh
agent. Let's see if I have screen if I
don't have
Let's see if I don't have screen
sharing.
Okay, cool. Uh I'm going to disable
screen sharing really fast while I copy
the curl with my OpenI key. Um and then
I will bring it back.
clear. Okay.
Um I'm going to screen share again.
So if I run this API key uh this
request, I can just see that it
literally cached nothing. And the reason
it didn't cach anything is literally
because I just have too small of a
context window. So if I just increase
this context window
by
make this a real resume example that is
dense
like all the stuff.
Cool. Let's copy and paste this and
let's go run this again.
It still didn't catch anything. I have
to make it even bigger. But the whole
point is right over here. You need to go
ahead and actually understand why this
is happening or not happening. And part
of the reason here is just I know this
is too smaller, too uh too small of a
text.
>> Do you show the token count?
>> It's right here.
Oh,
>> I see.
They won't even trigger caching here
>> like
triple the resume.
>> And just [clears throat] to be clear,
you're just running the same request
twice and seeing if it auto caches it
based on the shared prefix.
>> Exactly. And what I'm doing here is I'm
just trying to have it triple the resume
and that'll do some stuff probably.
And like hopefully I'll make it long
enough. But the way that I can test this
is just I can keep making test cases
until
I'm satisfied with the final output and
I'm going to see if it's actually long
enough where
um the model to get a lot slower.
Uh I'm still not long enough, but you're
getting the point of how I would go do
this. I know that open is probably
catching about 1024 tokens based on what
they said in their docs. So in that
case, I'm just going to make an example
that has 1024 tokens. And I ran into
this personally myself a few times when
I was unit testing some of the code that
we write because I was like, "Oh, why is
caching not working?" Well, it turned
out I literally just wasn't implementing
a long enough prompt and it would just
break all the time. But once I actually
implemented a big enough prompt, I could
consistently see hits on caching
pretty well.
Um, other questions from anyone?
Otherwise, I think we're 20 minutes
over.
I answered Vijay's question. It's about
cloud code proxying. I'm actually I'm in
Austin this week with the uh Gauntlet AI
squad. They have like a school here for
learning AI engineers. And apparently
one of the one of the students here
built a thing called CC proxy that lets
you just like strip all of the traces
out of your quad code running locally.
>> That's cool. That's cool. Um I guess
that's it for today's conversation in
that case. Um thank you guys for
joining. Hopefully it was educational
and hopefully everyone learned a few
things. We'll have a new topic for next
week that I think will be hopefully just
as educational.
>> It's going to be dope. Thank you all for
coming. Thanks Vybob for running the
session today. And uh thanks everyone uh
thanks everyone here.
Bye. Blair.